i want to turn our attention to a topic
that i think this is my least popular
view that i have
i don't care the truth is what it is
and i don't i don't care to be popular
if
if it means changing my views to
something that is
not correct the sin spinach has become
very popular lately you know i'm talking
about that jamaican oregano the devil's
lettuce you know what i mean jazz
cigarettes i'm talking about marijuana
on the left they love smoking the gange
and on the right
all too many conservatives have gone
along with the fad
to legalize marijuana well one of my
absolute
favorite writers out there madeline
kearns who is a staff writer for
national review
and a contributor to the spectator and a
wonderful musician by the way you can go
look her up on youtube and things like
that
she has a very courageous piece out
there talking about
why conservatives should not embrace big
dope
and all of the dopey things that are
going to go along with it maddie
thank you for being here thanks for
having me michael and thank you for
caring about this topic
my my pleasure i would you know and i
say this by the way as someone
i'm not saying that when i was young and
irresponsible i wasn't on occasion
a little young and irresponsible but i
never really cared
for marijuana it just didn't do it for
me i've smoked cigars since i was about
three years old i've always enjoyed that
in moderation i always enjoy a drink or
two or depending on the evening maybe a
little more than that
but marijuana never really did it for me
and i'm
it's just amazing to watch this happen
in real time that
everyone in the culture including the
so-called conservatives are embracing it
it's funny too because
you probably are better known for
dealing with this issue of
transgenderism you've done some of the
best work out there
on the transgender question i would i
would also encourage people to read
read matty's investigative work on that
but somehow i think that the marijuana
issue might be more controversial
even than the gender question yeah it's
really interesting and
again i'm going to play the outsider
card here and say that i came
to america it's an outsider i'm not
i don't suffer from the same sort of
ideological blinkers that i think some
people do
and there is this false dichotomy here
with the marijuana question
that either we have this terrible
horrible frightful war on drugs
or we have this wonderful no problem
gold rush or in this case michael a
green rush
which really is all about money and so
what i'm saying here it's a very
moderate piece it has very careful scope
i'm saying hey have you considered this
enormous pile of health concerns okay
and i can i can show you
the evidence for that and if you haven't
considered them may i just ask why
because
they're pretty glaringly obvious of
course
you know i've got a number of friends
especially growing up in new york
i have a number of friends who are
really really into it you know
that's like their their absolute
favorite hobby and but they're i notice
a lot of them are
very anti-tobacco so the same people who
will hotbox a camry you know and make
the whole thing reek of skunk
will tell me that i'm not allowed to
light up my cigar and i say hold on a
second here
even putting the taste of it aside if
you're gonna tell me
that that my cigar or cigarette
certainly you know even more so
have all of these health concerns and
these questions of tar and carcinogens
and potential cancers or emphysema
do you think marijuana just has no risk
of any of that at all it would seem to
me that they're
they're pretty similar in their risk and
yet what the the group for legalization
the group for decriminalization whatever
the pro pot people they
totally seem blind to it that's
absolutely right and
the other parallel of course with
tobacco is the way that the industry
behaves
so this is a very familiar story in
american life unfortunately we had it
the first half of the 20th century we
had big tobacco
big tobacco said don't worry about
tobacco it's wonderful for you
good for health good for digestion good
for the nerves they had doctors coming
forward and seeing this
in fact it wasn't until the 1950s when
the british medical journal
did a study on doctors who smoked okay
because 85
of doctors at the time smoked and that
they began to say hmm
there seems to be an awfully high uh
link with uh
lung cancer and um could there be
something there now of course the
important thing to remember about
epidemiology
is it takes a very long time to
establish a causal link
if you spend a lot of time speaking to
scientists speaking to researchers
you will notice that they are very
cautious people they are cautious in
their conclusions
they plod on at torto's pace but the
thing is
is that is an unfortunate combination
with the gung-ho
industry chats who would have you
believe that this is the best thing
since sliced bread there's no problems
to be seen
nothing to see here nothing to see here
but actually if you read my piece and i
encourage that people
do you will find that i have actually
gone through the medical literature for
you
so you don't have to and there are some
very sexy charts in there
that show a very very striking
correlation with psychotic incidents if
you think psychosis
is not really that big of a deal not
that big
of a deal compared to lung cancer well
you might want to read my report because
it's not very attractive
it ruins lives it ruins families it
ruins communities
it does nothing gets me going quite like
a good chart
but it's true there are there are plenty
of sexy charts in there
and then even beyond this question of
psychosis which to me you know is pretty
serious
you know getting a cough or some awful
disease from tobacco that's bad too but
psychosis also something to avoid
you get into the money there's a lot of
big money here there's a lot of
where there's big money there's going to
be big political influence and that
might be skewing the debate
that's absolutely right michael and it's
worth saying you know this is something
that
that is a problem on both the left and
the right we have
andrew cuomo cuomo talking about how
wonderful it is we're gonna have all
this
money and then of course he tries to
justify it by saying oh we'll put it
back into you know minority communities
who have been harmed by the war on drugs
as if that's like you know what's the
logic there it makes no sense
but yes money is the big driving force
here and listen
these people are not especially discreet
okay they say things like i quote a guy
a tech entrepreneur who
when washington state legalized
marijuana in 2013 he said on the record
we are big marijuana we are going to we
are going to make more money than
microsoft okay
it's all out there guys i'm i'm simply
pointing to the facts
don't shoot the messenger uh it's funny
because i i've
actually gone back and forth on this in
my own mind should i invest
in marijuana seriously because i i know
that if if the trends continue as they
are
there's a ton of money to be made right
unless unless people go in and fight it
and regulate it or whatever
so the part of me that wants to make a
bunch of money is very into that
but then the part of me that thinks this
is bad for the country
says maybe maybe i'll make my money some
other way but there's no question
there's a lot of
a lot of momentum behind big marijuana
and one thing that troubles me as a
conservative is
is how many people on the right have
gotten into this when i think of
marijuana
i think of those filthy hippies rolling
around the mud at woodstock
smoking smoking their joints in in the
60s
and yet now there are some people on the
right who
who would have us believe that the
freedom to
puff the magic dragon is somehow
deeply conservative it it makes us all
edmund burke
where does that come from yeah this is
just this kind of like
un unscrupulous enthusiasm for any
market influence and we've we've
seen this as an excess on the right for
years you know we've
in fact the same people who are saying
oh they're overreacting about big
tobacco it's fine it's fine and then you
know the big pile of dead bodies in the
corner and they go
well maybe we're wrong but uh carry on
carry on are now making the exact same
mistake you know wake up people smell
the very pungent smell
that's that's a very good point i do do
you think that then
the the way back is is through the
through the science you know to show hey
look we've got these
sexy charts as you say and they're all
going to show you they're going to show
you how
deadly or you know all the health
effects of this or do you think it's
through
say political philosophy to say look
regardless almost of the science this is
not something we want for our country
this is not going to lead to human
flourishing
this is a very a foreign element in our
country and so
uh we just want to diminish it because
this is a self-government and
that's what i'd like it depends who
you're talking to michael i think that
conservatives
for whatever reason they're more
cerebral they uh
they like philosophy and they can be
persuaded more handsome too yeah yeah
but with with the left you know we if we
make the case and it can be made i have
made the case
from the public health point of view
then you will actually find that any
honest broker will have to look at that
evidence and they will have to say
okay what is my response to this do i
have a counter argument that's stronger
or do i accept that hey she's got a
point and um
this isn't this isn't really all isn't
that great you know i i hate to be
a party pooper you know social
conservatives hate to be part of yours
of course
but i am the person who's showed up to
the party and noticed that not
everybody's having a good time
some people are very sick some people
are you know blowing marijuana into the
face of the dog
they don't seem entirely all there i'm
wondering if that's
maybe a party that needs to be rethought
in some essential way
so you think this could also be a wedge
issue on the left in that
the the left they're they're obviously
quite enamored of
public health experts and and a politics
based on public health
and so as much as they might love you
know
turning up the jukebox and puff i don't
really know what these people do but
you know as much as they they might love
uh pot
they they might prefer their kind of
politics of public health
yes i think it is a wedge issue on the
on the left and i'll give you another
reason not just does this
big dope resemble big tobacco it also
resembles big pharma's role in the
opioid crisis
now i don't want to suggest that it's
exactly the same thing and that we're
going to see
the same level of devastation
necessarily i mean i don't know
is the answer i don't know how much
devastation this is going to cause
but the fact is that there are people
trying to make money out of this and
they're putting money
way before public health and we've seen
this before
who get where is most ravaged by such
money-making it's poor communities it's
places that we're already vulnerable
it's minority communities
you know so i think that actually if the
left
there are definitely people on the left
who this argument could appeal to
i i should hope that's the case because
you know the it is bizarre that we've
now got
a lot of people in this country pushing
for legalization amid the worst drug
overdose
crisis ever and you know i'm lucky and
that drugs have never been my thing
aside from
a little uh you know little little
marijuana in college
it's the hardest drug i've ever tried
and i really didn't get that into it
but i do know people for whom it has had
very serious
consequences people who were highly
intelligent
who let's say they started smoking when
they were 12 or so
they just became dumber i saw them i saw
it happen in real time
i saw this happen in college i've seen
this happen after college people who
will wake and bake
and something i love that you talk about
in your piece is
looking at the feedback from actual
daily or more than daily or three or
four times a day marijuana users
who say you know this isn't all that
great this isn't
as anodyne as i was told this would be
i'm having real side effects here and i
don't really like it
yeah that's exactly right and i just
want to make clear uh that i don't
judge anyone who takes marijuana and the
villain of my piece as as evidenced by
the cover so it's the cover story and
the artist did a brilliant job of
depicting the big dope um uh it is the
is the industry i'm taking
aim at the industry here because i think
look for some people that's a pretty big
temptate
temptation to take drugs you know life
can be difficult life can be boring for
goodness sake you want a little holiday
from reality as huxley put it
i understand i understand i spent quite
a lot of time on the various reddit
communities
going through self-reports of users and
as you see michael
they are reporting some pretty
disturbing things panic attacks
you know difficulty breathing
hospitalization
vomiting paranoia these are things
that people who are using these drugs
are reporting and
they're looking for answers they're
going to the deepest darkest corners of
the web
for answers why can't we get some
answers from
journalists why can't they get some
answers from politicians holding those
industry leaders to account you know
we've been talking about big marijuana
that industry benefiting here
we haven't really talked about big
dorito you know or big big munchie which
obviously is a little
downstream of that i i think your point
is so apt here
that part of it is yeah people you know
they just want to have fun or whatever
they want to there's the pain of life
but it's also just boredom people are
kind of bored and so
they're flailing about and don't really
know what to do and this this creates an
opportunity for
an industry to crop up sort of within
the law but outside of the law
to really take advantage of this moment
and i i think they they are taking
advantage i think you you did an
excellent job
in in your piece outlining that i highly
recommend that people go
check it out maddie where can everyone
find you
at madeleine kearns on twitter it's at
madeleine kearns and that's m a
d e l e i n e k e a rns
that that is actually kind of a harder
it doesn't totally roll off the tongue
but i i
encourage you encourage everybody
m-a-d-e-l-e-i-n-e-k-e-a-r-n-s
at twitter maddie thank you so much for
being here read more from maddie in
national review and the spectator and
and go listen to her music too on
youtube
thank you so much as always